père ne ment dans l'école merci madame
la ministre
la parole est à monsieur alain moyne
bressand pour le groupe l'est
républicain
madame la présidente monsieur le premier
ministre
hier vous avez annoncé vouloir à peut
apporter des réponses pour l'emploi mais
plus de deux ans après la loi touraine
vous vous apprêtez à publier de nouveau
décret sur le conte pénibilité qui
suscite une grande inquiétude chez nos
pme mesures complexes modalités flou
critères ambigu lecomte pénibilité est
une véritable contrainte pour les
entreprises françaises
le pacte de responsabilité que vous
brandissez comme un étendard cache en
réalité tout un tas de mesures qui
empoisonnent la vie de nos entrepreneurs
quand il faudrait au contraire les aider
et les encourager je vous donne un
exemple la publicité des bilans pays par
pays qui figure dans le collectif
budgétaire actuellement en discussion
dans notre assemblée n'est en réalité
qu'une obligation pour les entreprises
françaises de communiquer leurs données
stratégiques alors concurrents
internationaux
monsieur le premier ministre vous croyez
vraiment que c'est avec ce genre de
mesure que l'on défend la compétitivité
de l'économie française
que veulent nos entreprises des mesures
durables un environnement normatif
claire et stable des règles fiscales
incitatives fx que veulent nos
entrepreneurs moins de charges moins de
contraintes car ce sont eux qui créent
l'activité et l'emploi
que veulent nos entreprises une france
qui ne vit pas au dessus de ses moyens
qui ne soit pas l'exception économique
en europe avec les 35 heures est
maintenant un conte pénibilité complexe
et générateur de contraintes
il y a quelques mois vous aviez accepté
de reporter certains critères devant la
montagne que représente cette mesure
pour nos entreprises
il faut aller plus loin et le supprimer
bien merci monsieur le député la parole
et à madame la ministre des affaires
sociales de la santé et des droits des
femmes
si madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés je voudrais vous
rappeler monsieur le député que la mise
en place d'un compte pénibilité a pour
enjeu de répondre à la différence
d'espérance de vie que connaissent nos
concitoyens ceux qui sont exposés à
certains facteurs de pénibilité vive
jusqu'à dix ans de moins en bonne santé
que les autres français c'est donc une
mesure de justice
une mesure de justice forte qui a
commencé à entrer en vigueur puisque sur
les dix critères lesdits facteurs de
pénibilité identifiés par les
partenaires sociaux et non pas par le
gouvernement quatre sont entrées en
vigueur dès cette année et je peux le
dire dès l'année prochaine des salariés
pourront bénéficier de départs anticipés
en retraite
grâce aux droits qu'ils ont accumulés
mais reste les six autres facteurs de
pénibilité et le gouvernement a toujours
indiqué sa volonté que la simplicité
soit au rendez vous et c'est pour cela
qu'un travail approfondi a été menée je
veux remercier en particulier christophe
sirugue qui avait que d'autres a mené
une mission pour voir comment simplifier
la mise en place de cette mesure des
décrets d'application seront publiés
autour de la fin de l'année qui
viendront confirmer deux grandes
orientations de simplification d'une
part les facteurs de pénibilité
entreront en application non pas au 1er
janvier de l'année prochaine mais au 1er
juillet de l'année prochaine pour donner
aux entreprises le temps de s'adapter et
de mettre en oeuvre les critères définis
et par ailleurs un autre décret viendra
confirmer que les fiches d'exposition ne
seront plus de la responsabilité des
entreprises mais des caisses de retraite
qui auront la responsabilité
d'informer les salariés vous le voyez
monsieur le député cette mesure de
justice sociale se mettra en oeuvre dans
la simplicité avec le souci de du
travail des entreprises
merci madame la mine